hello everyone
and welcome to today's live broadcast
looking
beyond pcr isothermal amplification
our webinar is presented to you by dr
agna olinope
and dr romiga skirgala i'm kristy jewell
of labrutz and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
brought to you by labyrinths and
sponsored
by thermo fisher scientific for more
information on our sponsor please click
on the sponsor logo
on the left side of your screen
now before we begin i would like to
encourage you to get the most out of
today's webinar
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
simply type them into the ask a question
box on the left and click send
we will answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation click on the support
tab
found at the top right of the
presentation window or use that ask a
question box
on the left this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits
following this presentation those
credits can be obtained
by clicking on the tab at the top right
and following the process
to receive your credits i would now like
to introduce today's speakers
dr agna almanate product manager custom
molecular biology products management
group
thermo fisher scientific and dr romigia
skirgala
lead r d manager ngs library preparation
and protein
in vitro evolution group thermo fisher
scientific
for complete biographies honor speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr almanate and dr skirgala you may now
begin
your presentation
thank you for a nice introduction hello
to everyone
and hello to everyone interested in what
isothermal amplification can
offer for your research so today
our topic is looking beyond pcr
and isothermal amplification
today we'll talk in general what kind of
group of techniques fall under this
common term of isothermal amplification
and we'll concentrate more on the
multiple displacement amplification or
mda
and its importance for world genome
amplification
and as well the story of the development
of
one unique ecv 29 dna polymerase
uh another isothermal amplification
technique that we
will discuss is loop mediated isothermal
amplification
or lamp and finally
we'll give some insights on the
applications of these techniques
for diagnostics
so let's start from the term itself iso
means equal and
equal means that this kind of reactions
isothermal amplification reactions can
occur at the same temperature all the
time
this makes them very convenient and
at many cases eliminates the need for
expensive equipment in general
nucleic acid amplification is a
technique used to
amplify starting material and
it is pivotal for all types of research
in life sciences in diagnostics in
agriculture and forensics we will find
these
techniques being used
because of these characteristics
isothermal amplification
offers many advantages over pcr as i
mentioned
no expensive equipment is needed
the chances of contamination are reduced
and
these type of enzymes are not so
sensitive to reaction inhibitors
and in many cases
tests that are out of laboratory
environment can be developed
and such test tests can be used
in field situations of point-of-care
tests
over the years there has been a list of
enzymes
discovered that can carry out these type
of reactions
so the list of of them has been growing
and
so has been growing the methods
that were developed using these kind of
enzymes and depending on the
starting material would it be dna or rna
the enzyme that takes that carries out
the amplification or
other factors in the reaction
there has been a multitude of isothermal
amplification methods developed
so you just have to pick the one for
your needs and
keep amplifying the number itself of the
enzymes for the thermal amplification is
long
but also the applications
and the techniques where these kind of
methods
are used has been growing
global market of applications has been
increasing since the
development of these techniques in the
early 2000s
these methods are used in many areas of
research and diagnostics we will find
them
in blood screening for example to
detect smps or small nuclear repeats to
track the inheritance of
disease genes they are also used
for infectious disease diagnostics both
directly in points of care facilities
or even at home and also in hospitals
also the use of such techniques are
growing in cancer research for for
example for
cancer-specific molecular biomarkers
detection
and as today we can see
the area that's been growing most
probably
is infectious disease diagnostics where
these
tests using this isothermal
amplification
techniques become very important
out of all the isothermal methods that
we have
and that have been developed to date now
we will talk about two and
you may ask why why why choose these two
methods
we think they represent the two very
important
research areas so first of all we'll
talk about the
mda multiple displacement amplification
and mda is mostly used in genome studies
this type of technique is very versatile
it offers extensive genome coverage
which is
very important in this field of research
it gives us high dna yields from a very
small amount of
starting dna material starting any
material can be
even a single cell mda offers
low amplification bias which is one of
the main
pain points of the researchers doing
this kind of
studies and what's behind
what enzyme is behind all of this
method is c29 dna polymerase
another method that we
are talking today about is lamp
or loop mediated
isothermal amplification and we chose
this method to talk about today
because it's one of the most important
methods for rapid pathogen detection
this method offers a very simple
reaction setup
fast results it can be used in the field
conditions
and because of the polymerase that
carries out of
this reaction the bsm or bsd polymerase
such reactions are very inhibitor
tolerant
so even crude dna or any samples can be
used for the
as the starting material
okay this was the introduction
and i'd like to hand it over now for my
colleague remigius to talk more about
mda and world genome amplification
thank you dr almanate now before we pass
it over to dr skirgala
we would like to ask our audience our
first question
are you currently or planning to perform
whole genome amplification
simply check the yes or no box and we
appreciate your participation
okay dr skirgala you may now begin your
presentation
hello everybody thank you arnie so
my name is remy scargyla and
i'm about to continue our webinar at
this point
i would like to cover whole genome
multiplication using
multiple displacement amplification
technique driven by c29 dna polymerase
and special development of thermo tissue
scientific
xvi 29 polymerase designed for
more efficient mba reduction
first of all a few words about multiple
displacement amplification technique
it is used for non-specific dna
amplification
the mda is performed on single-stranded
dna by annealing of random
polynucleotides
key enzyme in this process is c29 dna
polymerase which elongates primer
and complementary dna strand is
synthetic
at the moment the polymerase encounters
double-stranded dna region is started to
displace
upstream dna spray the displaced dna
strands
being being single stranded is a perfect
template for new priming events
as the reaction continues new new dna
strands
are synthesized generating
hyper-branched structure
which preserve original genetic
information of template
dna
once again the key enzyme in multiple
displacement amplification is
c29 dna polymerase from bottle subtle
stage
which has an exceptional strand
displacement activity and processivity
of up to
40 000 bases per single binding event
nda driven by random priming and
p29 dna polymerase could easily
understand
dna amount more than 10 000 volts
and generate enough of material for all
subsequent applications
dna amplified by vga could be used in
many different downstream genetic
analysis applications like sender
sequencing
next generation sequencing genotyping
with microarrays
single nucleotides polymorphism and copy
number variation analysis
a number of research areas require dna
amplification
it could be g banking single cell
analysis genetic disease research
etc etc
single cell analysis is fast-growing
fields which is looking for differences
in cell population at
single cell level for genome and
transcriptome heterogeneity analysis at
single cell level it is necessary to
have an acid
specifically to one single cell so
separation could be done by
the illusion or using some specialized
instruments like
fluorescence activated cell shorter
nowadays it is also very popular to
compartmentalize cells in emulsions or
micro wealth
once the individual cell is accessible
its genetic information could be
analyzed
and again in some workforce we need
nucleic acid pre-amplification
returning back to a non-specific nucleic
acid amplification we could identify
three different
groups of amplification techniques so a
it could be pcr
based
like degenerate oligonucleotide prime
pcr
or primary extension pre-amplification b
hybrid techniques like linear
amplification via transposon insertion
loyalty or multiple unneeding and
fluting based simplifications cycles
and finally again back to multiple
displacement amplification
specifically for multiple displacement
amplification
scientific has designed exercise 29 dna
polymerase
the enzyme was developed using
ingredient revolution technique which we
named
isothermal compliant compartmentalized
self-replication ics
the gene of wild type p29 dna polymerase
was cloned into a plasmid and the enzyme
was expressed in a sheriff called itself
the library of newton's variance of p29
polymerase was generated using error
problem pcr
actually has called cells expressing the
mutant polymerases were
compartmentalized and
water in all emotions containing no more
than single structure compartments were
prepared
selective called cells were disrupted
using lysozyme treatment and repeated
cycles of freezing following
released c29 dna polymerase could
amplify its
own genome located in a plasmid by
performing mda a certain condition
the screening for more efficient nd
enzyme was performed at increased
reaction temperature
and reduced amplification time final
variant of dna polymerase was identified
after several iterative
streaming cycles
newly developed newton p29 polymer
enzyme
was tested in the reaction comparing to
wild type enzyme at standard 30 degrees
celsius and
increased 40 degrees celsium reaction
temperature
dna amplification is presented as the
number of amplification faults at
different reaction patterns
the curves for newton's p29 dna
polymerase
and red and while test enzyme data
points and blue
for the first to house dna amplification
at standard 30 degrees celsius
red and blue triangle and the
temperature is similar
for both enzymes however later on
wild type polymerase slows down
meanwhile newton's t29
reaches uh about 30 000 false
amplification comparing to 10 000 volts
for wild type 6
let's take a look at md reduction
performed at 40 degrees celsius
red and blue square at this temperature
wild type polymerase is essentially
unable to perform md reaction blue
squares
meanwhile newton's enzyme works at
optimal temperature
and the reaction is about two times
faster and
about 30 000 false amplification rate is
achieved within three hours of reaction
red squares
based on newton's polymerase variance
coming from invis-revolution approach
thermofish scientific has launched
commercial
enzyme equify 29. this enzyme was tested
by performing
uh mda on sorted single cells from human
telons
or six micrograms of human genomic dna
the experiment was performed in three
steps workflow
comprising stylizes neutralization step
and mda
performed for one hour 42 degrees
celsius
total total workflow time is about 2
hours which includes
about 30 minutes of enhancement the key
features of
mda performed by aqua 529 dna polymerase
are increased traction temperature
higher reaction speed
better product yield and reduced
amplification
on this slide gcs of single cell dna
pre-amplification is
shown as a normalized coverage curve for
sequenced
human genome regions of different gc
percentage
an ideal coverage curve would be flat
line
at 1 all over the gc regions
the control red curve which was
generated by sequencing of unamplified
genomic dna
is our gold standard with rooting square
deviation value of 0.22
next two best curves are yellow supplier
c
and green equifax this root means square
deviation values of 0.24
and 4.29
the normalized amplification coverage
evenness
all over the genome is shown in this
slide
in a new case all affected bases have to
be sequenced
at equal coverage of one however nothing
is
perfect in the real world and logos
standard
red curve has the event value of 0.75
cell dna amplified by equify 29 has the
best event score
of 4.5 among all tested commercial keys
another important indicator of whole
genome amplification events is
math score which describes how reliable
we could perform component copy number
variation analysis
it is a common knowledge that mda-based
whole genome amplification
have better coverage overall good single
nucleotide polymorphism calling
low gc bias but due to intrinsic nature
of some hot spots in
amplification initiation it is not as
good for coffin under variation
analysis comparing to hybrid whole
genome amplification techniques like
bulbar
it is not a surprise that mapped curve
of eq59
amplifies single cell genomic dna is not
the best among tested kids
however it is still at pretty good level
and could be used for
analysis
finally would i like to show last but
not the least
light of mine where you find two
references of our collaborator dr ramona
stephanos
from a single cell genomics center
bigelow united states
uh he has used our sf5 dna polymerase in
his single research targeting microbial
cells
taking into account that bacterial
genome at single cell level is about
1000 times smaller
comparing to human it is not a surprise
why the data is published in
nature communications and cell
at this point i would like to give a
word back to my colleague
please thank you dr
gala it's now time for our second
audience poll
now to our audience our next question is
are you currently
or planning to develop diagnostics assay
using isothermal amplification
again simply check the yes or no box and
we thank you for your participation
dr almanate you may continue with your
presentation
remigious thank you very much for an
interesting talk
and now let me continue with a
lamp and where this kind of method
can be used so
talking about lamp or in other words
loop mediated isothermal amplification
first of all what we have to say is that
this method is really irreplaceable
when immediate fast pathogen diagnostic
is needed
this method because of its
characteristics
offers speed robustness simplicity
and ease of detection so
what kind of amplification
is lamp this method was
first described in 2000 by a japanese
scientist
and lamp amplifies dna
with very high specificity and
this polymerase is very efficient under
isothermal condition
the polymerase that carries out the
reaction
bsm dna polymerase has very strong
strength displacement activity
and lamp becomes a standard method for
isothermal diagnostics let's look into
more detail how the lamp reaction
is set up so there are only so many
components that go into the reaction
so what is needed is the polymerase
a dna sample that can be a
poorly purified dna even and
also a set of specific primers
now what i would like to point out
is primer design is crucial for
performing lamp amplification
the primers have to be specific for the
regions
that are at certain distance from each
other
all sets of primers including a pair of
outer primers
and a pair of inner primers have to be
used
and then at least six distinct dna
regions
recognized and at this point
when everything falls into the place
with the right primers
and the specificity the reaction can
continue with speed
when the sm dna polymerase is coupled in
a reaction with
reverse transcription enzymes we we can
also develop methods for
rna as a starting material
as the reaction continues we can see
that lamp is only simple
at the first glance in fact there is a
great complexity
in the course of this amplification the
final products of the reaction are stem
loop dnase
with several inverted repeats of the
target
these cauliflower-like structures with
multiple loops
are formed from the hybridization
between the alternatively inverted
repeats
of the same strand and
what is probably the best about
lamp is that the result of
such reactions due to very efficient dna
amplification can be
visualized even by the naked eye
as the reaction thirds turns turbid
the alternatively changes in color can
be detected
and when developing lamp
based assays even mobile applications
can be used to
visualize or detect the positive result
so the benefits of the lamp method for
rapid diagnostic essays
is evident efficient amplification
enables rapid diagnostics in the field
virtually any pathogen can be detected
using lamp
the pathogens include plant pathogens
plant viruses for example
infectious disease agents like malaria
zika virus tuberculosis the list
continues
the tests have been developed even for
coronavirus detection using lamp
the testing can be done outside of
sophisticated
laboratories even in the field without
any
sophisticated equipment this broadens
the
surveillance efforts that can be carried
out
and this type of reaction is highly
resistant to
inhibitors and allows us to use
complex samples such as plant tissue
blood
urine saliva and
these type of samples require minimal
processing so
when the reaction conditions are right
they can continue
even with poly purified sample
at this part let's see where isothermal
amplification methods
are used in diagnostics first of all
i'd like to talk about bulb genome
amplification
and it's used in new generation
sequencing workflows
the whole genome amplification comes in
very handy
when nucleic acid extraction
does not give us enough starting
material
for example when starting material is
just a single cell then in the starting
steps of the
nucleic acid preparation very processive
dna polymerases such as 529 or
equify 29 dna polymerases
come in very handy for the first
amplification of the
starting material that can then be used
in the library preparation
purification and finally
when the ic continues to sequencing and
data analysis so
whole genome amplification is one
of the key reactions allowing
us disease diagnostics and in general
research that is done with a material
that comes in
very small amounts
examples of such material that we
probably
are more familiar with for example
when non-invasive prenatal testing is
being performed
or liquid biopsy of tumor cells
that circulate in our blood
on this slide let's see where the lab
comes in
in molecular diagnostics so for this
method two very clear
areas can be determined so
lamp is widely used in diagnostics in
the field
and the advantages of this method
include
fast reaction speed as short as 15
minutes
usually the reaction takes place in
around 30 minutes up to 1 hour
but even results in 15 minutes can be
obtained reaction is
inhibitor tolerant it's easily
visualized and so the
challenges that lamp reaction brings
with itself is
one of the most important is that it's
mostly quantitative versus qualitative
so it gives us the answer yes or no
the other challenge with this reaction
that it has to be developed
for multiple targets
when we design the primus is usually to
detect
one pathogen if we want to detect a set
of pathogens
in the same reaction setup it's a bit
challenging using
this type of polymerase
however innovation comes to this field
as well and multiple
target detection is starting to be
possible for lamp as well
another field where lamp is applied
is in portable diagnostic devices
many such devices are now being
developed to
facilitate disease diagnostics in
point-of-care institutions or even at
home
it offers a simplicity of operation and
simplicity of
pathogen detection one can
get a yes or no answer
in virtually no time
and also at the accuracy that is
equal to laboratory however this also
brings in a challenge
to adapt such a reaction to the
conditions in a small device and get
same quality
automation for portable device will also
require
lyophilized assay which would be stable
in a room temperature
and lyophilized acids can be achieved
using enzymes that are adapted to liar
ready
condition
so here you can see a list of
liar ready enzymes and what is so
special about the lion ready
enzymes these enzymes have
virtually the same functionality
and performance over conventional
enzymes but they are formulated with a
buffer
containing very low glycerol content
this small concentration of glycerol
will not inhibit the reofilization
and such enzymes can also
keep the assay stable at room
temperature
so assays that require such temperature
can be developed
using exactly these enzymes if you are
looking to develop
any type of assay that has to take place
in
room temperature then both equify 29 and
the bsm dna polymerase
are available also thermal fissure
offers
many lie ready enzymes used in reverse
transcription
pcr or real-time pcr
as shown in these tables
when developing an isothermal
amplification assay or any molecular
assay
thermo fisher offers not only enzam but
also
custom off-the-shelf plastics for your
platform
or instrumentation such as
thermal cyclers and they can be even
private labeled or
with software customized for your
specifications
and lastly also oligos and primers
which are critical for successful lamp
amplification for example
can be ordered for your target
and they come in high quality
by partnering with us for products and
services
you will not only get the highest
quality
but also an experienced supplier that
has worked with
many leading molecular diagnostic
companies
here at thermo fisher we understand both
the critical raw materials and
new technologies that can help you
develop the cutting edge products
and we are dedicated to our diagnostic
partners
so we are trying to deliver
value beyond the product
if you are interested or if you found
any of the products that
you would like to know more about please
find more information on our website
i would like to now conclude today's
seminar
and thank the audience and also my
colleague amigos for presentation
also lab roots for hosting the webinar
and i want to open it up for
questions now thank you
thank you dr almunate and dr skirgala
for your informative presentation
we will now start our live q a portion
of our webinar now to our audience
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
and we will answer as many of your
questions as we have time for
okay let's get started we have some
great questions already coming in
let's start with this one thank you for
the webinar
i am currently using bst dna polymerase
for
developing a diagnostic assay how
difficult is it to swap
bst polymorase with bsm polymerase
and what is the difference between the
two enzymes
so thank you for the excellent question
to answer the question how to
how to swap bst polymerase for bsm or
is it is it difficult to do
the answer is no it's not
difficult these two enzymes are
basically the same they come from
different uh
type of bacteria of the same genus
specialist
and they can
simply be changed easily for your
essay so bsm can be used instead of
bst
thank you our next question thank you
for the very helpful content i'm looking
to develop an rt lamp assay for covid19
which isothermal amplification enzyme do
you recommend
for rt lamp assay thank you
thank you again very important question
today
so to answer the questions
when developing an rt lamp essay
[Music]
i would like to recommend
to use a combination of two enzymes
i would recommend to carry out the
first steps of the reaction um with a
rna transcription because the the virus
as we know
has an rna genome and
to use rna target
[Music]
we need to have the reverse
transcriptase
for the first step so from thermal
official
portfolio that would be a
superscript 4 or maxima and
then go on using the bsm polymerase
at the same time if the conditions are
worked out
or after the reverse transcription
amplification steps
and using the bsm the
lamp reaction can give you a quick
result and
visualization just to remind that both
of these
type of enzymes the reverse
transcriptases
and bsm
comes in line ready format or are
available
in live ready format and
rt lamp assays for kobit 19 can be
developed
for ambient environment
thank you and we have time for one more
question i need to perform
wga on rare cells obtained by
microdissection from
ffpe tissues do you know if equify 29
has been used
for wga on this kind of sample
uh yeah so actually a very interesting
question
[Music]
so nucleic acids extracted from
ffpe samples are heavily fragmented
and typically are too short for
efficient amplification by standard
mda reaction driven by p29 or aqua529
so that for special workflow would be
recommended to generate long complicants
before md election to proceed
thank you now before we go i would like
to thank our audience for joining us
today and for their interesting
questions
those questions we were unable to answer
live today and those submitted during
the on-demand period
they will be addressed by our speakers
via the email address you provided at
the time of registration
i would like to once again thank dr
agnet ominate
and dr romigas gergala for their time
today and their important research
we'd also like to thank labyrits and our
sponsor thermofisher scientific for
underwriting today's educational webcast
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
laborats will alert you via email when
it is available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now we
thank you for joining us
and we hope to see you again soon